the original said one was destroyed in  World War two Conrad Sousa rebuilt it 40  years later from memory by then it was a  museum piece up till the 1950s computer  data was still entered using punch cards  it wasn't till the 1970s that powerful  processors made computers more common in  1981 IBM launched the first home  computer  the IBM 5150 soon after the Apple  Macintosh was launched the first  computer with a graphic display in the  1990s Apple turned computers into  lifestyle products and status symbols  with brightly colored casings the  company again revolutionized the way  people and computers interact with the  iPhone and the iPad and the revolution  continues so-called wearables blur the  line between human and machine like  wristwatches that monitor vital signs  cyborgs used to be science fiction now  maybe they're our immediate future